Film Courage: What do you recommend to a writer
that is too much of a perfectionist?
And on the flip side maybe one who is too
loose and maybe a little sloppy?
Daniel Calvisi, movie studio reader, screenwriter
and private screenplay consultant: If you’re
too much of a perfectionist you need to understand
that you need to get it out of the door at
a certain point or drop that script and move
on to another.
A writer writes, they write more than one
script.
You can’t obsess over the same script for
years.
I’ve done it, everybody has done it.
It’s your baby and you want it to be perfect.
It’s good that you want to be super detail-oriented
and you want it to be of a high quality level
and not have any typos or spelling errors
and really blow away the readers.
So it’s going to take away some time to
write.
It’s going to take years to write that great
breakthrough script but you have to get it
out the door at some point or drop it and
move on.
So if you’re planning to get it out the
door then you have to cut it off at some point
and say “I’m going to submit this to a
contest or a manager or a producer or whoever
and it’s tough to get it out the door because
you’re never sure if it’s exactly ready.
But it’s probably never going to be perfect.
It’s probably never going to be the exact
submission ready level that that needs to
be.
It’s subjective to the reader so it’s
hard to say “Okay, this is absolutely where
you should cut it off and you should send
it out the door.”
It’s your choice and it’s one of the toughest
choices for writers when do you submit?